today's video is sponsored by surf
[Laughter]
sharks
hello there hey how you doing this is my
mom
that's my son today we have gathered a
handful of israel's dms that he has sent
to strangers on the internet there's
gonna be four messages
and nancy it's gonna be your job to
guess which one is his
i think i'm gonna do great you're gonna
make my dick spit oh jesus
that my son wouldn't say that to
somebody his his dick don't even spit
that's a funny lie i don't care what
nobody's that's a great line yeah that's
good
his dick don't even spit probably drools
i don't know if he's going through
puberty all the way
[Music]
i think she's talking about his penis
specifically
she was rustic yo
spit i know cause you got your daddy
dead
that [ __ ] just goes drip drip drip
just wanted to let you know you have
some cute on your face
this is like a 20 something euro
14 kind of thing yeah drop down a little
bit
as i thought about it i wouldn't have
took this from no 20 year old you remind
me of my favorite tv channel you know
why
because i would never want to change you
i emoji i emoji
skeleton emoji y'all got corny ass lines
i'm not even confront you the way y'all
be doing this
is corny but anyways but you know what
ladies you can't even complain because
uh your pickup lines are even more trash
oh you guys are not good
yeah ladies pick up line uh i sent a
booty pic i said hi
i say hi yeah yeah if i reply to your
story you don't reply back uh
so stretches these lines are ladies your
lines are trash too yo girl
yeah the [ __ ] does skeleton emoji mean
dead laughter
but there's no rolling on the floor
laughing there's just i i did
like i see you dead you remind me of my
mom can i get your number
he would say that he would
three that third one you remind me of my
favorite tv channel
you know why because i'll never want to
change you
[Music]
yeah that's swag that's him
that's me nancy baby listen let's see
let's see nancy
you're a cool dude nancy you a cool
dude we can't hang out we'll roast your
son
for no reason a couple of brews roast
your son and that's it
yeah yep he's wack do you have any
advice for me on how to talk to women
stop
[Laughter]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
geez yo oh
oh she's good awesome and you know what
a thing is
it came from the heart i felt that it
was real she didn't want to be mean
she's like all this is whack it's not
working
let them come to you because boo boo
it's not working nancy you're the one
you're the real mvp on this one nancy
god damn
today's video is sponsored by surf shark
vpn
so vpn is basically an application or
web extension that you could use on your
web browser or on your internet
to mask your ip address basically hiding
your location
from whatever website you're interacting
with now you might think
why would i want to hide where i'm at it
doesn't matter well unfortunately there
are places that block you
based off of your ip address and so if
you're trying to view
online content the online so download
certain things
based off where you live those things
could be restricted
now i like watching tv shows feel me
sometimes
they're foreign feel me and when that
happens
basically i use a vpn to be able to
bypass that so i can watch what i want
to watch because i feel like the
internet's at its best
when everything's accessible if you use
promo code abba and preach
you get 83 off plus three months free
so take advantage of the deal watch what
you want to watch and don't be
restricted by anyone's barriers
you deserve to go wherever you'd like to
go except
you want to physically fly then buy
yourself a plane ticket
stop don't i'll tell you why because
uh that gift of gab you feel like you
have it's not there
so what you're gonna have to do you're
just gonna have to clean yourself up
real nice
like and then present yourself we
actually have a twist for one final
round in this game
okay and we actually got a text that
nancy sent to her husband
and uh israel you're going to have to
guess which message she sent
i get nasty with it too i love it
i always feel like you're looking
directly into my eyes with this
picture of heart eyes i think it's cute
you know
i think it's kind of you know old people
is what it is he trying to get back
at us oh you don't think i got some gab
imma come for you wash his hook
you missed you missed i like when you
wear that crisp
white shirt
[Music]
absolutely not do you have any raisins
what are raisins in old people layman
terms strawberry balls
oh i'm wet
[Music]
mm-hmm
hey she's a boss bro let's go shout out
to nancy she's a boss
don't give a [ __ ] i can see a lot of
kids would be embarrassed by a mom like
this i think it's kind of
oh it's amazing whatever is that's me
she is grown
i'm grown and i can talk about things
because i do grown folk things
do you think that's something that your
mom would text 100
get in it to win it how does that make
you feel reading that
you gotta do what you gotta do
[Music]
like three of them do seems like things
she would have since
but seems like a reasonable assessment
that it would be the first one that's i
was saying i'd be like hold on baby look
how
good what you trying to do tonight
israel
you are correct okay my husband was
trying to be real nice because i do be
sending nasty ones but you probably
don't want me to be on camera with that
kind of stuff but i see nasty ones too
in fact one time i sent it to granny
what did you send to her i was like hey
you want to have sex and then i realized
i had sent it to granny
she didn't respond whoo
that was a hard one to uh come back from
i was uncomfortable
i just need one kiss damn lol
that's not him respectfully looking with
the eyes emoji
yo i don't know if it's my old ass
probably it's my old ass
emojis
i'm not if you write emojis to me
i'm gonna ask you to use your word
there's some people sometimes i'm trying
to have
grown-ups trying to have conversation
and they're like
yo what's up what you doing and they
send eyes
what does that mean oh that means
they're taking an interest use your
words
that's my older i acknowledge that's
because i'm [ __ ] old yeah
yeah but then again my mom use emojis
like it's on sale like he just uses
emojis fires her being you can't be
pissed off at me
and sending me a pissed off emoji it
takes the pissed off
away the the eyes one though that one's
uh
that was a pretty good one yo what the
[ __ ] you did and you sent me an emoji
like
i'm not gonna take you seriously the
next one says don't nobody do it like
you
and when they try they don't even come
close
read this one let me hear it don't
nobody do it like you and when they try
to don't even come close
you see how it flew off his tongue don't
nobody do it like you
that's a double negative last one says
for the love of god please sit on my
face
first of all my son does not practice
connie lingus
pre-marital sex he doesn't do it
they both got a good sense of humor i
appreciate you bro i appreciate you yeah
they're good
they're really good this is a
conversation i could not imagine having
with my mom even after 10 lifetimes
so you know shout out to them it's not a
matter of i would or wouldn't i can't
you can't see yourself i can't even it's
not even a possibility yeah
yeah yeah i mean like i see myself going
to space before i've seen myself having
this time i understand okay
ufos come on i'm ready this [ __ ]
yeah yeah we know you have the forehead
and it's not gonna work [ __ ]
yeah but i i could have my passport does
not allow for conversations like that
i could yeah i refuse to believe that
somebody would have sex with him
that's what that's really what it is all
right okay didn't know that's how that
was gonna go
i think respectfully looking okay
it's my son i think i think that's my
son
that is incorrect oh it's the don't
nobody do it like you because i said it
the way it flew off your tongue
that's whack who fell for that this girl
from a week ago look at the shoulders
yo this mom is dope but i forget you
this
nancy you dope you're a dope woman
you're a dull woman that [ __ ] is way
she's amazing that's how i know she's
not the one
like you what you're talking about wow
your lines whack your dm's whack your
durag
whack next card
them titties titian them titty is
titting
that damn do you find it offensive if a
guy says he likes
juicy women
oh yeah you never seen that meme before
she keeps looking at him like my son's
so [ __ ] late he's so [ __ ] he came
out of my [ __ ] totally
i did not want to labor for this lame
[ __ ] no
you took that from your daddy
oh so you fine heart do your thing
that's my son he loves to say do your
thing when he sees somebody doing good
he likes to
like tell a lady you know he ain't even
tripping about my bbl do your thing mom
can you let us know what bbl stands for
uh brazilian butt lift where they do the
fat grafting they're gonna take my
stomach and put it where
it was supposed to go are you excited
for your mom's bbl absolutely
until she goes to the islands and wears
nothing but the little strings then
dental floss and stickers
don't take pictures hope they last in
the sea
i ain't mad at you nancy live your life
do your thing
all right so out of these four which one
do you think it is it's it's the fourth
one
nancy you are correct i knew it how was
this experience for you too
it just confirmed how whack he was and
that i'm going to have to
um do an arranged marriage he's not
going to get it right
if you are just classy you have some
substance
and you're a good person he is he has a
sweetheart he's very giving
and he will make sure that in life you
are happy
that's important to him well i
appreciate you for the people at home
she is right you know if you want to
send your donors this way
i'm a good guy here we go that's it i
got a good gpa
yo nancy's involved nancy's like nancy
lance is the bomb
nancy she's the bomb yeah you i know a
lot of people look at this like man
what an embarrassing mother would you
shoot she's amazing listen i think
parents are open with their kids without
these kind of conversations
i wish my parents was more open about
their sexuality because honestly i had
no education
about any conversations i had to live in
the dark about that stuff your whole
life so
you see how i could get with my parents
yeah yeah yeah so i think it's way more
responsible and i think it's healthier
to have an environment where people can
talk like this so
shout out to nancy you know what i'm
saying um from your resident misogynist
we're a big fan
that's it it's crazy because yeah you
remember one day i had a party for my
birthday
oh we got story time with preach hey
listen hey listen you want to hear this
story time you can go to patreon that's
it for today
if you guys enjoyed it go to the truck
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]